ride the rural roads in our south of
Chicago to John Keith nurs farm and
you'll reach the results of a rough year
incomes have been trending lower and the
trade war definitely exacerbated the
lower price for a lot of our commodities
raising corn soybeans chickens and
donkeys he has endured a trade war
Midwest floods swine flu and now a
corona virus that slashed exports to
Asia
we had mother nature unleash one of the
worst years of weather on us so you take
most of the prime growing areas across
the Midwest we had trouble even getting
the crop planted and in many areas we
didn't in the swing states in the
Midwest in Pennsylvania which depend
largely on agriculture and farming
president Trump narrowly won in 2016 on
a promise to restore jobs but for his
20/20 re-election bid there are economic
warning signs farmers are not doing as
well as they would like in manufacturing
employment levels in the Midwest went up
substantially in the first few years of
the Trump administration but now the
rate of growth in manufacturing has
slowed from the Midwest population
centers to the plains job growth has
been anemic in the first three quarters
of 2019
jobs grew at a rate of more than 9% in
Nevada and Colorado and less than 2% in
Wisconsin Ohio and Michigan hardly the
Midwestern jobs boom the president
promised amid the manufacturing and
farming slowdown Democratic activists
note several key Trump states switched
parties in the 2018 midterms Michigan
Wisconsin they all tossed out the
Republican in the governor chair and
they and they put a Democrat in in
November that you can see the writing on
the wall that he's moving these key
states as agriculture in the auto
industries struggled through the
president's recent trade war with China
some niche manufacturers like Atlas Tool
Works in Illinois still prosper the
industries that were in defense
aerospace work has been very busy was
our best year in a hundred years and
we've seen continued
strong growth but here in the Prairie
states the president's voters can be a
stubborn lot as not a true supporter of
Trump a private forum it is voters like
him who are the president's best hope of
maintaining his firewall in the American
Midwest John Hendren al-jazeera Chicago